[Müzik]
[Alkış]
bu
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
oh
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
CH
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
CH
[Müzik]
TH
a
[Müzik]
k
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Öncelikle Herkese selam hepiniz hoş
geldiniz
konuşmama gitar çalarak başlamak istedim
sakın bundan konuşmayı sevmediğimi
düşünmeyin gitar çaldım Çünkü müzik
benim kendimi en iyi ifade ettiğim
yol Özellikle bu şarkıyı seçmemin de bir
sebebi var bu şarkıda yani believer da
şöyle bir bölüm
geçiyor
okuyorsunuz kırgınım küçüklüğümden beri
Tüm insanlar anlar küskünlüğüm
yüzümden şiirlerimi ise yalnızca birkaç
kişi beni gören Bana sarılan beni
sarsan beni hisseden birkaç kişi kalp
ağrısından acıdan söylerim
şarkılarımı Aslında ben de benzer
hislerle çalıyorum
gitarımı
Ben Rabia Burdur Bucak'ta Küçük Bir
ilçede
büyüdüm muhafazakar bir ailede büyüyen
bir elektr
gitaristim muhafazakar deyince aklınıza
farklı karşılıklar
gelebilir ama bu noktada Ailem beni her
konuda
destekledi
biraz duraklı Kusura
bakmayın bugün size E uzun uzun Hayat
hikayemden bahsetmeyeceğim
ama müziğin benim için ne anlam ifade
ettiğini müzik yolculuğumda
karşılaştığım engelleri ve benim için
değişimin Kendisinin ne demek olduğunu
anlatmak
istiyorum çocukluğumdan beri
düşünürdüm başörtülü biri olarak kendime
uyumlu olma kalıbına sığdırma ihtiyacını
hep
hissederdim bu hissi sadece müzik
alanında değil hayatımın pek çok farklı
alanında
deneyimledim spora hep yatkın biriydim
Basketbol oynadım kaykay sürdüm tekvando
yaptım farklı Spor dallarında birçok
başarılar elde ettim Hatta odamın bir
bölümü madalyalarla
dolu şimdilerde her hafta halı sahada
Futbol oynuyorum ama futbol oynarken
duyduğum eleştiriler enteresandır
ki topu vuruşum ilgili
değil işte sen Erkek çocuğum musun biraz
kız gibi davran kızlar futbol oynamaz
gibi cinsiyetçi tutumlarla yalnızca
müzikte değil ilgilendiğim Diğer
alanlarda da
karşılaştım bunları gördükçe
uyumlu olmak denilen bu kalıbın toplum
tarafından kabaca inşa edilen küçük bir
kutu olduğunu fark
ettim Evet biraz ufak tefek biriyim Ama
böyle küçük bir kutuda yaşamayı
istemem kendi Sınırlarımı kendim
belirlediğim sürece yapmaktan keyif
aldığım şeyleri yapmak benim için çok
önemli
önemli ve beni bu kadar İyi hissettiren
şeyi yani gördünüz
müziği sırf toplumun beni uygun gördüğü
bu kalıba sığmadığı için bırakmaya asla
ve asla niyetim
yok Ve ben de bu
sebeple müzikçe müzikte özgürce Kendimi
buldum ve değişimin sınırlarını
zorladım değişimden kastettiğim şey şu
değişimin kendisi olabilmek için
korkularımızı ve toplumsal baskılar mızı
aşmamız
gerekiyor Beni ben yapan seçimlerim
vazgeçmeden kıyafetlerimin şeklimin
Sesimin görüntümü ötesindeki içimdeki
rabian aldığım
güçle toplumsal geleneksel beklenin
beklentilerin bir adım ötesine
geçtim
kendi
benliğimi keşfetmeyi
öğrendim
Aslında kendimi değiştirmeden değişimin
kendisi
oldum Peki bunu
gerçekleştirmek söylemek kadar kolay
mıydı müzik yolculuğumda
Özellikle sosyal
medyada sayısız zorlukla karşılaştım
sizi biraz Bu yorumlarla baş başa
bırakacağım insanlar beni
inanamayacağınız kadar çok konuda
eleştirdiler
bir yandan inancımın metal müzik
ideolojisine ters olduğunu hiç Çağdaş
gözükmediği
başörtümü çıkarmam gerektiğini Öte Bu
yaptığımın haram olduğunu cehennemde
yanacağımı bilemeyiz Allah korusun da
kıyamet alameti ve hatta Deccal olduğumu
söyleyen bile oldu o sırada ben Google'a
yazıyorum Deccal nedir sonra
enter Aslında Tek yaptığım sevdiğim şeyi
yapmak ve bunda en iyisi olmaya
çalışmaktı bu yorumları yapan
insanların hayatta bir şeyleri tutkuyla
ini çok çalışmanın keyfine varmalarını
varmalarını isterdim Kusura bakmayın
Aslında mesele başörtülü olmamam kadın
veya erkek olmam bile değil sadece bir
şeye tutkuyla bağlanmış
olmam Bu yorumların hiçbirini
umursamıyorum desem doğru
olmaz çünkü arasından sadece bir yorum
ve buna benzer yorumlar beni gerçekten
deli
ediyor şu
Yorum bu yorum Bana emeklerime yapılan
çok büyük bir haksızlık mış gibi
geliyor video atmaya başladığım ilk
zamanlarda Olacakları az çok tahmin
ediyordum ya bu yüzden videolarımı
yüzümü göstermeden yüklü sırf insanlar
beni bu şekilde yargılamasın diye bir
bir kalıba sıkıştırmaya çalışmasın diye
ama ne zaman Cesaret edip Tamam artık
ben buyum Ben olarak var olacağım dedim
işte o zaman işler biraz daha değişmeye
başladım insanlar artık gitar çalmam la
ilgilenmiyorlar bunun yerine dini
inancımla kaşıma gözümle Hatta başörtümü
rengini dahi eleştiriyor lardı
yani müzik yaparken tüm benliğimi Yok
etmem inançlarım
vazgeçmem ve belki de kadın olmamam mı
gerekir ya da ne yapayım kafamı mı
keseyim yani böyle kesmekten
bahsetmiyorum bu şekilde kesmekten
bahsediyorum müzik sanatçının kişiliğini
ruhunu fikirlerini
hissettiklerini ortaya koyduğu bir alan
ve tüm bunlardan ayrı
düşünülemez ve Ben hem karakterim
sebebiyle hem de bu gibi yorumlara
Vereceğim en güzel cevap olarak Belki
Yarım saatte çıkartabilecek bir parçayı
ben evde oturup 81 saat hatta Günlerce
çalışıyorum ve bunda en en en iyisi
olmaya
çalışıyorum ve bu sebeple de çok fazla
gelişiyorum
Yani aslında size karşı yapılmış kötü
bir yorumun böyle faydalı etkileri
olabiliyor Tüm bu eleştirilerle
yüzleşmek özellikle başlarda benim için
hiç kolay
değildi işte Tam da bu Yüzleşme
zamanlarımda bu işe devam etmem
gerektiğini çok iyi
anladım Çünkü beni
güçlendiren hayatla baş etmeme yardım
eden şey müziğ
müzik hayatıma devam edip etmemek benim
elimdeydi ve en nihayetinde kendi
hikayemi
yazmak benim
elimdeydi bir de çok sevdiğim müzisyen
bir arkadaşımın beni hep motive eden bir
sözü vardı Eğer gerçekten
iyiysen seni
eleştirirler kendimi geldiğim noktada
şanslı hissediyorum
sosyal medyada başladığım bu yolculuğu
aslında Sadece gitar çalmaktan ibaret
olmadığını Anladığım bir sürü deneyimim
oldu bana gelen çoğu mesaj beni hem
duygulandırıyor hem de doğru yolda
olduğumu Bana
kanıtlıyor genç
yaşlı birçok farklı görüşe sahip kadına
ilham olabildiğim
hissediyorum
özellikle yıllar sonra
bugün sosyal medyayla başladığım elektr
gitar yolculuğuna birçok farklı şehirde
kadın müzisyen arkadaşlarımla konserler
vererek devam
ediyorum konserler verirken
Pardon konserler verirken
sanal dünyada yaşadığım şeylerin
dünyadaki gerçek karşılığını çok daha
net
görüyorum etkisini çok daha iyi
anlıyorum en büyük
konserlerimiz konserlerimiz
birlikte daha ii
hissetmeleri bana bize o kadar iyi
geliyor ki size
anlatamam Son olarak size şunu
söyleyebilirim kendimi değiştirmeden
değişime kapı
açabildiğimiz inatla sevdiğim şeyi
yapmaya devam ettiğim için ve başta da
bahsettiğim gibi İslam'ın özünde ne olup
olmadığını bilen muhafazakar ailemin ve
bugün doğum günü olan annemin desteğiyle
şimdi bu
noktadayım ve bir tedex konuşmacısı
olarak
karşınızdayım beni dinlediğiniz için
teşekkür
[Alkış]
ederim